you know we've seen each other a few
different times and chad and whatever
but
this is more of a real conversation than
we've ever had and
you're a really
i like i mean i like dan i like
you're you're smart you've thought about
things you're compassionate
um
you're also convicted like i feel like
you have beliefs that are strong in all
different ways not just religious but
other ways too
and um and so i'm really glad that this
conversation is
led so strongly with dan and
you know we didn't yeah because i really
like dan i mean yes larry makes people
laugh and these other roles make people
laugh but you know it's uh it's magic
for comedians you can get people to fall
in love with you with a role but it's
really like the deep true love is is
comes through when you show who you
really are and so i'm glad we've had
you've been so open about so many things
you know you know what i'm always
i'm always open i'm always honest i
don't there's no need to lie to anybody
and you know when you said that it's
funny it reminds me of another person
that said that uh to me to me was uh
john lasseter from pixar
you know
uh
john when people ask me
um uh
john lasseter said to me that he loved
it that i voiced mate and he got to hang
around me because he said uh
uh not only does he he said the same
thing he goes man i love larry the cable
guy it's so funny he goes but i really
like hanging out with dan i really like
dan and he said
uh
the closest you'll get to me and uh with
is mater because mater is the larry
voice
the mater is my
is is my personality is my character
um i
i talked like larry the cable guy for
mater but when i came up with the
inflections and the hey me sally hey
like when i came up with all of the
heart stuff
that was basically i was just throwing
me into it just putting me into the
character
but i used the larry accent but that's
why john lasseter
that's what he loved about it he said
man i see both of you it made her after
hanging out with you i see both of you i
see the character and i see dan in mater
but it's just funny you say that because
he said the same thing
and uh and uh but you know hey i'm like
everybody else i'm not perfect i do my
best i i try to be kind to everybody
sometimes i sometimes you know it is
sometimes you just blow a top and you
got those days where you you lose your
self-control and you and you just got to
be alone and i have very few of those
days
um uh
but uh everybody does have those days
obviously i'm not perfect and i let me
say this as well to you
and this isn't a butt kissing session
for either one of us but i have to say
this for you because you said it's just
hard when you go out in public and you
have to do this and you have to do that
and i get it man i get it sometimes
there's nothing worse
than people
then you know what i mean if i sometimes
if i could i would never leave the house
just to avoid
people sometimes you get in that mood
you know what i mean
but i'll tell you we went down to a race
i've been to a ton of races i've been
the grand marshal a bunch of times
but the last few times i've taken my
kids because they're old enough to enjoy
it but we were at that race and we were
at the race in kansas city
and uh man you were so kind to my kids
my daughter
has been a dana kim patrick fan ever
since that day in kansas city
because you were so nice to them and
they were so they were just really
enamored
at how nice you were so they they both
did when they left their their favorites
were danica patrick and ryan newman
because they were so nice
oh
that's so sweet thanks for sharing that
story so so that's so you do do a really
good job at that
and i know a lot of times what was
taking a little extra time with the kids
because they can't reason like an adult
can reason and go you're working or you
probably have somewhere to go but a kid
doesn't really know you know a kid
you know the kid just goes oh my my
favorite person just walked by and
didn't say anything to me or ignored me
or you know they weren't very nice you
know and that sticks and you also
they're so impressionable i mean the the
molding of a child i mean it's happening
most aggressively until about the age of
about six
six to eight and so to to have an effect
on a kid like that is is a really cool
thing and you know you were talking
about a lot about kids we're talking
about pixar and cars and i found it
amazing to hear just how
impressionable how meaningful
it was for you to be a part of pixar
versus let's say the blue collar comedy
tour which that's where i mean that like
puts you on the map i mean six years of
touring with you know a lineup of
amazing comedians i mean you know it it
made all i mean i remember watching it
as a kid you know it's it was a huge
deal but pixar is what hits home and i'm
wondering what why that is
oh man i'm so old you were a kid
watching this
um
i hear that about me too so hey people
are like people you know even i feel
like oh my god my boyfriend even said
he's like you know when i met you i
thought you would i thought you were i
thought you were going to be a lot older
like he's like i didn't realize you'd be
you were you know in your later thirties
i because he goes because i remember
being in high school and you were a big
deal and i'm like oh my god
see that's awesome that he would say see
i get stuff like wow he's still alive
that's a whole different range
hey man we're just we're just just
climbing the ladder
oh my gosh now what was your question
it was just about pick sorry just you
know i'm wondering like what's the what
makes it hit home in your heart so much
that that is the thing that is the most
seemingly from what i have heard
really one of the most meaningful things
that you've done
well that's that's really meaningful
because uh first of all it's it's it's
an organization and they make movies
that every huge
a-list actor wants to do they all want
to do it for the kids or or
or their uh grandkids
or
they all want to do a pixel movie so the
fact i not just got not only got picked
to do a character in one but it turned
into three and a theme park i mean it's
really a dream come true um i liked it
because
i had kids
and um i was able to bring in a whole
nother group of people that's why my act
started to change because i had kids
once you have kids
you start to think differently you have
different priorities it's not about you
anymore it's about your kids and you
want your kids to grow up good you want
you want them to give them a good
foundation you want them to see their
dad and some things that are really cool
that they so that's when i just started
re writing things differently
keeping the same thing neatly
the character's the character you can't
flip you know
but writing jokes that i'm more
comfortable with with kids
and since pixar came along uh that was
perfect um because i'd already started
to adjust my act and try to change
everything and then here came pixar but
i think the cool thing about it was john
hired me because of the voice he loved
the voice the voice was his tow truck
and i had worked so hard
on
on um uh developing this
and marketing myself and doing these
radio stations
uh for no pay a lot of them for years
no and just in the back of my say
wondering
at some point
this is going to have to lead to
something because it's getting more and
more popular it already led to the blue
color comedy tour
so you know
let's see what else happens and by guys
uh i would have never dreamed when i
first did that voice on stage
when in 19
uh
probably
in the late 80s
never would i have dreamed that that was
the start of a pixar character i would
have never dreamed and it's just really
cool to see the development from the
very first time i went on stage the very
first time i went on stage that i'm a
big rodeo fan so i used to watch
yeah i used to watch mesquite
championship rodeo with donnie gay
uh on sunday nights
and uh i went on stage with a cowboy hat
one time because i used to do some
characters i just put a hat on and for
three minutes i went well we rode that
ball yesterday he took us up to pay
window you know i took a shot in the
shorts but we win it that's what it
started with
got an okay laugh
the next day i went up and i did it as a
cable installer because i literally had
a cable installer come to our house in
florida
and he was just kind of a bumbling guy
that thought he had the
wrong house but
he wasn't sure and you know because the
numbers on the house but and so i just
went on stage for the first time and i
went hey uh do you order cable
well somebody's ordered something here
because we've been driving around this
neighborhood uh 7
45 yeah well this is the house
you know and i literally did like a
three minute bed that got pretty good
but i would have never dreamed in the
main years that that night
that would have developed into
the character mater and so is that a
little guy does this cable guy know who
he is
i have no idea
he's probably dead now he was probably
70 40 years ago or however long it was
but
um yeah so it's just that's why it was
really cool it was just a culmination of
something that i created in my head
that just boom and that that's just a
cool feeling you know
um to go backwards in time then to the
in between from the birth of you know
this voice and doing stuff on the radio
and then all of a sudden you know you're
the voice of you know this huge
character in cars
uh is the blue comedy tour and blue
collar comedy tour
what was that like i mean i just
what is it like to have a room full of
comedians like i'm sure you guys are
i mean i think from my experience
sometimes people
don't realize that you might not
interact that much
right um
in certain environments like there would
be times i go to the racetrack and you
know there's certain drivers that you
literally would only see in their car on
the track and you'd actually never see
them in passing and other points and
maybe during driver intros or something
like that but just for a split second
you don't hang out with them right but
people put them so what was it really
like like were you guys ever hanging out
or was there separation you know i know
foxworthy's flying in on his jet and you
know
you know doing doing doing the thing but
was there was there real camaraderie was
there not um how was it really well
first of all the funny thing about the
progression of blue collar comedy tour
was hilarious because
jeff flew in on the jet
we all flew in on delta
and then by the time the third one was
over
uh we left to go go home there was four
jets lined up
because jets are the best i know i'm
like sounds like i'm sure i sound like
such a dick right now but they really
are no they hey
absolutely i mean if you're blessed
enough to do it but here's the thing
about it people do what people don't get
about it
um
you don't take a jet unless there's
money on the other end
you budgeted out that when you want to
take family trips you can take x amount
and take the jet
you don't want to do it if there's not
money on the other end but here's the
thing about the jet
uh people like these blue collar guys
flying around well you know what it's
pretty hard to get from michigan to st
joe to texas to florida in four days
on commercial airlines you can't do it
and it and you want to be you work so
much
you have to find a way to get somewhere
quick so you can be with your family
that's what it was all about believe me
if i could have saved money getting
somewhere quick a lot cheaper i'd have
done it but you can't do it and be an
entertainer and do 280 days on the road
and still spend time with your family so
yeah i was one of one of the things was
i was fortunate though a lot of those
times i had a the family truckster we
toured in a tour bus together
so uh on those blue colored dates where
we could get there in uh eight to ten
hours on the tour bus we would just take
the bus out and i'd be my wife and my
kids it was awesome but as far as the
thing goes you know what jeff and i have
been friends since 1986 he's like my
adopted brother i love him with omar
um i frequently very infrequently ran
into ron white i knew ron
i met him a couple of times he was
awesome he was my friend i mean he was a
nice guy funny but i'd only seen him a
couple of times i didn't know bill
lingball for squat never worked with him
didn't know him i just knew he was on
there so when i joined the tour
that was the first time i was introduced
to those two guys but as we progressed
and toured together in shows together we
were a tight-knit group we all were very
close to one another we had regular
little brother fights like you would
normally have little snippets here and
snippets there and get mad here at
something but in the end at the end of
the night it was all good we would never
let that go into the next day because
not only did we have something good
going we didn't want to ruin it but we
were truly friends and we did truly care
about each other and we knew that we
never
uh we never got jealous of the other
one's successes because we knew the
minute one person got
something good happened to them it was
going to happen to us